truly the tales and songs fall utterly
short of your enormity
o Smaug the stupendous
they are the dwarves of Erebor we have
come to reclaim our homeland I offer you
my help how do we know he won't betray
us
don't there is no King under the
mountain nor will there ever be
and here with every victory this evil
will grow
Legolas is grown very fond of you
do not give him hope where there is none
oh wait oh into that mountain
have the only right
we can plan in our blindness
have you tuned
I found something in the Goblin tunnels
what did you find my courage good you
needed
Dragon Fire and ruin that is what you
will bring upon us he cannot see beyond
his own desire
I will not risk hey youtubers is Charlie
and they just aired the second trailer
for a desolation of smaug and we finally
got to hear Benedict Cumberbatch speak
as the voice of the dragon let me know
what you think obviously Benedict
Cumberbatch has done some voiceover work
before especially some really notable
stuff I'll try including the links but I
personally really enjoyed it
it was really fun to hear his gravelly
voice he really has this distinct voice
so it's easy to understand why Peter
Jackson and chose him as opposed to
another traditional voice actor I also
wondered about the giant spiders in the
trailer - obviously shell up is the big
character in the Mirkwood mythology so
I'm really interested to see if they
have a voice actor doing that part
there's nothing listed in the IMDB and I
couldn't find any information on it but
if any of you know if shelbs going to be
the movie be sure to let us know in the
description there's also this extra
subplot with Torrio and Legolas
obviously Lee pace is playing his father
Thrain de Ville and he did this wicked
[ __ ] block in the trailer but I think
based on the description of her
character that Peter Jackson has given
she's a Kingsguard and really can't get
married can't have children but let me
know what you think what did you think
of the trailer obviously they had a few
moments that we saw in the previous
trailer but the big stuff obviously the
spiders Benedict Cumberbatch and the
subplot with Legolas Senatorial so I'm
really looking forward to the next
trailer they're calling this the main
trailer so I'm guessing there's going to
be one or two more trailers with some
more Benedict Cumberbatch's Smaug be
sure to let me know what you think
though I'm also going to try and post my
various video for Game of Thrones Season
four be sure to subscribe to get that
you can click here to watch that video
as soon as I posted a lot of the
annotation and you can click here to
watch my other Hobbit desolation of
smaug trailer thank you so much for
watching high fives for Smaug
you